A lot of you have been asking us to debunk health fat so we went to LA to meet our friend Grace Helbig and try
Some of the weirdest wellness trends and search for the world's healthiest drink up first is shilajit used in traditional Indian medicine
Study shows the main active ingredient folic acid can help with alzheimer's disease and it may also help with Kidney stones
But some of the claims can't quite be backed up like it gives you better memory mood or "sharp intelligence"
- All right let's do it. shall we do it?
- All right cheers
*Moans of Disgust from shitjalit"
it tastes like um some sort of earthly element like dust uh
What is it some people call this sweat of rock is it like decompose into rocks basically in many ways is like eating soil.  so it's compost
wait it's dead compost
yes, basically all of these claims have no significant evidence to back them up and on the flip side it can actually cause toxicity because
They found heavy metal ions in them, and in some cases traces of Mercury and Arsenic
You know one brown color well-deserving up. There's 30 bucks. Oh. Oh, that's nice compared to the dirt water
This is like straight up. Yeah, so this is popularized by gwyneth paltrow's goop have you heard of that. Oh big-time that was
Essentially, it's like a supplement
So it just has random nutrients and chemicals in it you aligned with the cosmic flow of great achievement is
That me what I think they just put the mater sound smart because it works and I
When I say I'm a digital entrepreneurs
Researchers have found that the photosynthetic pigment, and Iii live does have antioxidant and anti-inflammatory
Properties, this is very similar to dark leafy greens like spinach which are really rich in antioxidants
Iii Live is a Bacteria and though. It itself is not toxic
it has been found have toxic strains within it some of these toxins can actually be deadly in wild animals and
People and also it has been linked to increased tumors and mice and liver cancer. Do you want to still drink sophie?
3 live
In this there is activated silicon
What do you think thank you?
So silicon brings up images of plastic surgery or nanotechnology
This chemical element is found in several of our foods and fluids and is related to good Bone health
But since it is found in so many foods including cereals bananas beer and even the water
We drink no human has ever reported a silicon deficiency, okay?
Why would I do this when I can have a beer is?
This is the quintessential La stereotype your green card. Yeah
Anti-cancer that's a lovely one of the claims is just bladder
Rx me yeah prescription yeah, and it says juice Scripture. Oh
Yeah, these statements have not been evaluated by evaluated by the FDA these products are not intended to treat diagnose cure or prevent any visit
When you just said anti-cancer because you can get away with claiming
Whatever you want as long as you have a disclaimer on the back somewhere. You can say like this will make you never die
So well we were in La we actually did get our hands on
What is allegedly the world's healthiest drink and got to try it this amazing beverage brings oxygen and nutrients to the cells of your body?
helps regulate body temperature
Cushions joints regulates your metabolism and gets rid of waste in the body
This is straight-up. Water. Yes, wow
And all those things are true
So, what is the healthiest drink in the world?
if it comes of the inclusion of all forgot to drink water and so that wraps up our
Search for the healthiest drink in the world. Thank you so much. Hopefully you feel extremely healthy. Maybe we're going to dive
Over and this is so necessary. Thank you. Thanks so much. You don't know what amount of food you just did